what's going on everybody welcome to
part 4 of our intermediate Python
programming tutorial series in this
tutorial we're going to be talking about
list comprehension in sort of generators
but really generator expressions and
we'll be talking about generators more
later on so first of all test start one
of the most common generators that
you've probably been using is range so
when you say for I in range of five this
does not generate a list 0 1 2 3 4 it's
a generator and it generates a stream in
the range of 0 to 5 which is producing 0
1 2 3 4 so but it doesn't do that and
save it all into memory as opposed to
say list comprehension or a list that
actually obviously would would store
that into memory so in Python 2 range
actually isn't a generator and it does
store that entire list in the memory
which is why if you in Python 3 you can
get away with saying like I equals range
this that's okay you're going to be just
fine when you do that right we can do
that real quick ok boom it's already
done all right but in Python 2 if you
run that code it's gonna be like like is
she's not kind of happen and you're
gonna have to close out a Python okay so
because it's generating a list and it's
just going to blow your memory so
generator now fundamentally we'll have
to keep hitting this point as we go
through this this entire course really
but list comprehension or a list is
going to be faster but it's going to use
your memory right it's going to use your
RAM to store that list and that's why
it's faster it's already loaded
boom it's in memory generators on the
other hand are going to be slower but
they're not going to use as much memory
and slower is like with an asterisk
because building a list actually like
when it comes time to to build and save
that list to a variable that can
actually sometimes be a pretty time
intensive process so actually sometimes
generators are faster but in most like
raw cases the generator is going to be
slower it's just not going to blow
your memory cool now that we have that
other way how do we build these things
so maybe you've seen things like I for I
in range 5 and maybe it's X Y Z equals I
for I in range 5 what the heck is that
so what that is is basically it's the
same as saying X Y Z equals empty list
or I in ranch not the same but it
produces the same output for some
aggression on that one for I in range 5
X Y Z dot append I okay these two things
do the exact same thing we can print X Y
Z and then do the same thing again okay
same output
so that's list comprehension now what's
it what about a generator expression so
a generator expressions literally the
exact thing just instead we use
parenthesis generator boom okay
but those parentheses make all the
difference because this is not going to
store this into memory it makes it's a
generator now so so for example if we do
print instead over here X Y Z X Y Z run
one of them's an actual list it's in our
memory the other one mmm weird it's a
generator object and what do we do with
a generator object well as you might
guess from before when we did I for I in
range 5 you iterate over a generator
object so in this case you would say for
I in X Y Z print I and then you're able
to iterate over it but the magical thing
about a generator is it was not it
didn't store that range or didn't store
this right as a list 0 1 2 3 4 as
opposed to this one so if this range
instead was this
don't try this at home I'll probably
regret this let's see what are we using
here five hundred thousand let's do that
we'll actually do that that'll help us
sort of visually time it I thought it
would be done by now but maybe not my
goal is to show you that as soon as
pretty much the list comprehension is
done the other range would be done
surely a range of 5000 is not too much
to ask it's too much to ask everybody
I'm so sorry haha
oh my guys were still e oh the problem
is we're printing okay yeah no that's
the problem
sorry dumb of course let's open that
back up again I'm pretty sure that's the
problem let's just say done try again
okay yeah so rather than this now let's
add let's go back to 500,000 or what is
this five million that's five million
that's okay we'll do five million okay
five million is acceptable five billion
okay that one's taken a little longer
took off 1-0 we'll see if that's any
fast there we go so okay that's a good
one so waiting done and then the Jenner
is like BAM right because we didn't need
to store it into memory okay so that's
what the generator was much quicker to
generate but then as you start to
actually want to iterate through it or
do something with it the generator is
going to take take a longer time okay so
that's an introduction to list
comprehension and generators in the next
tutorial we are going to apply a
function to one of these and also talk
about kind of embedding them into
themselves and stuff so if you have any
questions or comments concerns whatever
feel free to leave them below otherwise
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support subscriptions and until
next time